I think what Drake is really smart with
was the humility he decided to show in
the commercial with his dad
right like people you have to understand
like people like this is all high school
this will always be high school exactly
like the second you figure out somewhere
for most people between sophomore and
junior year of high school where you're
like oh [__] right if I make fun of
myself and I laugh at myself with my
friends they'll stop picking on me like
understanding the moves I think Drake's
understanding of anthropology and
psychology of like if I put a national
commercial for my beverage on where I
get clowned and my dad gets the girl
hey son hold my drink
nice turtleneck
like that is smart there's not a lot of
people who have the humility in the
country and Hip-Hop because you were
saying like everyone wants to be because
they want to be hard correct that's why
Drake wins because 100 and he's hot so
hello